pêche désire rendre hommage et un salué
cette jeune femme de chéu andréanne
marquis qui a remporté au cours des
derniers jours les grands honneurs de
l'aventuré occupation double alors andré
hahn a fait honneur à sa famille a fait
honneur à sa région elle remporté un
condo comme vous savez c'est legrand
plie mon seul des appointements madame
la présidente c'est que le cours d'eau
en question n'est pas allée verte dans
ma circonscription de rio du témiscouata
mais à montréal adrian des projets de
vie tout à fait exceptionnelle il s'agit
d'une jeune étudiante en communication
qui fait un travail remarquable
on doit le souligner est ce que j'espère
c'est qu'un jour on la retrouve dans
notre région et qu'elles puissent
profiter enfin participer à
l'épanouissement de notre territoire
merci beaucoup dans le présent